welcome to this video playing burrito
burrito and five wins two draws no loss
that sounds good should repeat this and
we'll continue with this with this
result okay I'm playing something
different here the Tory attack just for
the sake of variation of course it's a
very healthy opening cannot be bad why
develops in a logical way a little bit
like a reversed version of the Slav yeah
this is one of blacks main setups good
idea here's some cheek undefined okay
quince the sound okay I'm just castle d
6 okay so it gives me a form not quite
sure why but I'm taking this opportunity
I wonder yeah I wondered about if he can
castle he really be five so this is
interesting i can now let's let's play
the simple a simple path just take them
okay check came and now he has to give
up castling or go into this which is not
very attractive check okay so 841 i
guess a four is the better choice and
belongs into that position anyway and he
doesn't want to take them yeah now i
can't eat and play nice chat more with
the tempo that was important so that i
get 93 and he doesn't have to shoot you
five
so over here my night will come to d5
that is nice try to claim that i have
the better my name is and i'm probably
and not only trying i really have the
better minor piece under steam question
is if i want to play safe or not to
prevent be 54 good yeah i think i will
but it's not pretty it's all a totally
clear-cut decision i prevented that Jack
I already did check it takes now 97 wins
the rook I had an idea really with that
move but he didn't really reacted he
didn't really react b3 the ideas look a
form yeah I can cover that ideas rook a4
then look a one yeah where are you going
to before
yep so I'm going to bring the King up to
see form jackets probably a sound way of
doing it look a four is still an option
but why not bring the King up to you to
before yeah so okay for now that looks
good
yeah this a 5 for 20 when you went 85
that sequence was really very helpful
for me
yeah its trade stuff it's close to being
a being out of moves here so what about
this now I can take these six right come
on let's play it and I mean it it's a
very simple technical Windsong no use to
do anything fancy almost pre-move King
be three
so what is the easiest way to do this
night to a four picks up the pawn okay
black resigns yeah but he got a really
really awful position there on the
opening that was on normal 12 I mean
okay it's not terribly bad but there's
no particular reason to allow me to play
you for and then you for I mean why give
white at center you could have played d5
or the the most common way to play this
is something like this to get this
traded and continue from that it's
usually helpful to have one payoff minor
pieces exchange and here you know it's
all looks normal and now we went if five
and after that i think i can go d 5 with
an advantage or taking with a bit of
slight edge but it's there and 95 is
also helpful for me i believe so here
check yeah now you should probably move
the king this is not a good idea kingi
7s better they will probably do this
trying to use that square which now here
he's got group to aid with the tempo at
least and here on my moves come with
temple jan27 you form yeah i know you
went a six and after that I think it's
gets really tricky oh I could take be
six actually yeah of course i canno
let's rock d 1 and then Quincy six check
check hey I was only I was completely am
out here for for this end game I wanted
this end game which is just nice for
wide now after you loud c4 and it gets
it gets very one-sided
the need to change and blunt at that
point after which is pretty simple
technical play you know just some some
slide precise moves that are not
difficult geez v3 to make sure i can
take every porn that might be on c4
those squares are protected by the night
and the porn so he's dominated there and
i can just bring the King up Andrew gay
for as an additional tool to trade
Brooks and that's it's very simple
really okay well thanks for watching